tu ne peux pas ressentir l'humidité ce
que tu sens c'est l'eau sur ton corps ta
peau qui refroidit plein de signaux qui
te disent attention c'est humide mais
c'est que des signu extérieur on n'y est
pas directement sensible comme la
chaleur ou le froid c'est donc très
simple de tromper cette sensation si tu
t'assois sur une chaise froide en plein
été tu auras l'impression de t'être fait
pipi dessus magie même chose mets ta
main dans un gant et plonge-la dans une
eau glacée même si tu as aucun contact
avec le liquide pour ton corps c'est
comme si tu étais trempé peut-être qu'un
jour on sera assez évolué pour avoir des
hydrorécepteurs spéciaux sur la qui
peuvent réellement capter le sentiment
d'humidité pour l'instant c'est juste
ton corps qui te joue des tours en
attendant